with them thanks to jello zv4
subscribing with twitch prime really
appreciate that
let's go to our caller from the nine
seven three area code 973 is that Jersey
yeah hi how are you I really you are but
you also sound like you're on speaker
all jokes aside I wasn't here okay we
gotta clip this thank you I think
Oh God give me a second here let me let
me prom - when did you realize you were
such a big fan what clip was it that you
were like wow this is just really really
good stuff so before you two had the
impalas all that stuff I was a fan of
The Young Turks from there I kind of
just stumbled into you and a few other
people so like thank Jane for uh jinx
constant from recommending you guys
when YouTube wasn't biased you know they
recommended you guys now on my app
YouTube doesn't recommend you anymore
it's like whenever you post something up
or when you upload a B or then I'll show
it but other than that I can't look at
any past videos as a recommendation yep
it's weirds true that's a problem so I'm
pointing to those I think a lot of
people okay let me ask questions for you
you said you were brushing you
are you using like a super soft bristled
brush because that's you don't want to
use anything hard on your gums you know
it's cooler each I just picked up a
random toothbrush and use it okay yeah I
don't I'm not like I have this cap thing
that keeps my brush from being exposed
by the bacteria from the toilet because
you know when you push the toilet and
you should get to close the lid yeah
yeah my mom was like listen we're
putting these crafts on I use expensive
Ellen love it love sorry what how long
I've been in touch two weeks hold it I
saw that maybe it's Oh God
I can't listen to actual did you have an
ethical question I'm curious oh I did
well I thought I was never going to
reach you okay okay
because because because I always live on
the waiting list for your YouTube your
YouTube segments and I never reached you
so I was like alright and you know are
on live right this is live right now
yeah and I'm pretty sure I'm going to
look at my computer because I'd be I'm
like that's the whole way in my house
yeah oh my god making that joke out of
your shoes okay listen I really
appreciate the call your inspiration to
me it's the type of thing that we would
all be far better off in society if
everybody was as enthusiastic as you
okay my questions are PPT I think the
problem for some people like destiny is
that they want to have a foothold in the
trading negotiations but I don't think
um like people I guess can't understand
that traditionally speaking like in the
courts right corporations would have
like a monopoly of profit right if they
lose profit that they're immune from
countersuits and etc
I don't think they realize that so like
someone like you or Michael Brooks when
you explain that
you know there's immunity for clump or
corporations and multi millionaires they
don't realize that so I think that needs
to be like explain to them a lot of the
times were saying like like our destiny
uses like the the fine print in the
negotiation mm-hmm hello okay
hello all right it seems like he's gone
beat thief that was weird beat very
excited